This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Since the mid-1970s, almost every jazz musician has owned a copy of the same book. It has a peach-colored cover, a chunky 70s style logo, and black plastic binding. It is delightfully homemade looking, like it was printed by a bunch of teenagers at Kinkos. And Inside is the sheet music for hundreds of common jazz tunes, also known as jazz standards, all meticulously notated by hand. It's called The Real Book. When I started playing jazz, I remember the first thing
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。自20世纪70年代中期以来，几乎每位爵士乐手都拥有一本同样的书。它有着桃色的封面、粗犷的70年代风格标志，以及黑色的塑料装订。它看起来非常像手工制作的，就像是一群青少年在金考快印店（Kinkos）里印出来的一样。书里收录了数百首常见爵士乐曲的乐谱，也就是所谓的“爵士标准曲”，全部都是用手精心抄写的。它被称为《真实之书》（The Real Book）。我刚开始学爵士乐时，记得我吉他老师说的第一件事就是：好吧，你得买一本《真实之书》。那是制作人米哈伊尔·麦卡芬诺。每个人都有一本。如果你是一个认真的音乐人，这似乎是你理应拥有的东西。我的高中爵士乐老师伦纳德先生，他的桌子上堆满了《真实之书》。他告诉我，他其实是在这些书最初的出版地——波士顿的伯克利音乐学院——买到了他的第一本《真实之书》。
my guitar teacher said was, well, you gotta buy a real book. That's producer, Mikhail McCaffinall. Everybody had one. It just felt like something you were expected to own if you were a serious musician. My high school jazz teacher, Mr. Leonard, had stacks of real books on his desk. And he told me that he actually got his first real book at the place where they were originally published, Berkeley College of Music in Boston.
他刚到那里读大一。我听到人们谈论《真实之书》，《真实之书》。它在伯克利随处可见。到处都是。当你参加合奏课时，老师会告诉你，带上一本《真实之书》。我们要从那里面选几首曲子来练。但很快，伦纳德先生就发现，《真实之书》并不像他上课需要的其他教材那样。你不能直接在校园书店买到。以前有个家伙常站在马萨诸塞大道靠近博伊尔斯顿街的拐角处，他带着一个箱子坐在那儿，然后他就会说：
He had just arrived for his freshman year. I heard people talking about the real book, the real book. It was just all around Berkley. They were everywhere. You were told when you had an ensemble, bring a real book. We're gonna do some tunes out of that. But pretty quickly, Mr. Leonard discovered that the real book wasn't like the other books he needed to get for his classes. You couldn't just buy a copy in the campus bookstore. There was a guy who used to stand on the corner of Mass Ave near Boyleson Street and he had a box and he would sit there and he'd just,
嘿，想买本《真实之书》吗？想买本《真实之书》吗？诸如此类。根据伦纳德先生的描述，这家伙听起来就像是从ZZ Top乐队的演唱会上溜出来的。你知道，牛仔裤非常非常长，头发长到后背中部，留着大胡子。嗯，据我所知，他过去大约每两周就会被捕一次。我们被捕是因为《真实之书》是非法的。这本世界上最受欢迎的爵士乐曲集是一本完全未经授权的出版物。这是一本粗制滥造、自费出版的书，在没有获得音乐出版商或词曲作者许可的情况下创作。它在复印店被复制，在街角、汽车后备箱里，以及乐器店的柜台下秘密出售，人们用暗号来进行交易。《真实之书》如何成为这本爵士乐“盗版圣经”的完整故事，是一个复杂的过程。
hey, wanna buy a real book? Wanna buy a real book? That kind of thing. From Mr. Leonard's description, this guy basically sounded like he wandered out of a ZZ Top Concert. You know, Jean's really, really long, like mid-back level hair, big beard. Um, and as I understood it he used to get
这是一个关于当像爵士乐这样具有反叛性、即兴创作的艺术形式被编纂成册，并成为你可以从书中学习的东西时，会发生什么的故事。巴里·克恩菲尔德是一位音乐学家，他写过很多关于爵士乐历史和音乐盗版的文章。他也是一位萨克斯手，在20世纪90年代的一次咖啡馆演出中，他打开了他的《真实之书》。我开始纳闷，好吧，我们正在阅读所有这些曲子并学习演奏，
arrested about once every two weeks. And we get arrested because the real book was illegal. The world's most popular collection of jazz music was a totally unlicensed publication. A janky, self-published book created without permission from music publishers or songwriters. It was duplicated at photocopy shops and sold on street corners, out of the trunks of cars, and under the table at music stores, where people used secret code words to make the exchange. The full story of how the regal book came to be this bootleg bible of jazz is a complicated
那么这本书是从哪里来的呢？克恩菲尔德说，早在《真实之书》问世之前，爵士乐手们就依赖于他们称之为“假书”（fake books）的乐谱集。第一本“假书”的故事始于20世纪40年代。纽约市一位名叫乔治·古德温的人，在40年代初深度参与广播行业，他对追踪、许可等繁琐事务感到有些沮丧，于是他发明了一种他称之为“曲库卡”（tune decks）的东西。曲库卡是一个索引卡片目录，旨在让广播电台员工追踪他们在节目中播放的歌曲。卡片的一面有关于特定歌曲的信息。
one. It's a story about what happens when an insurgent, improvisational art form like jazz gets codified and becomes something you can learn from a book. Barry Kernfeld is a musicologist who's written a lot about the history of jazz and music piracy. He's also a saxophonist, and at a coffee shop gig in the 1990s, he was opening his real book. And I started wondering, well, we're reading all these tunes and learning to play,
作曲家、出版商，以及你需要知道的版权支付信息。而在另一面，他们印了几行简短的乐谱，只有歌曲的旋律、歌词和和弦，这样广播电台员工扫一眼就能快速回忆起这首歌。但这种简化的乐谱也让这些卡片对另一群人——职业爵士乐手——变得很有用。作为一种黑人艺术形式，爵士乐是从包括灵歌和蓝调在内的其他黑人音乐传统中发展而来的。
and where did the book come from? Kernfeld says that long before the real book ever came out, jazz musicians were relying on collections of music they called fake books. And the story of the first fake book begins in the 1940s. A man named George Goodwin in New York City, involved heavily in radio in the early 1940s, was getting a little frustrated with all the intricacies of tracking, licensing, and so he invented this thing that he called the tune decks. The tune decks was an index card catalog designed for radio station employees to keep track of the songs they were playing on air. On one side, the cards had information about a particular song.
到了40年代，许多爵士乐是流行的舞蹈音乐，许多爵士乐手靠在小俱乐部和酒吧里进行现场演出赚钱。标准的爵士乐曲目大多是来自百老汇或纽约词曲创作工厂“廷潘巷”（Tin Pan Alley）的知名歌曲，比如廷潘巷传奇人物科尔·波特创作的《日日夜夜》（Night and Day）。科尔·波特。
The composer, the publisher, the things you would need to know for paying rights. And on the other side, they had a few lines of bite-sized sheet music, just the song's melody, lyrics, and chords, so that radio station employees could glance at it and quickly recall the song. But this abbreviated musical notation also made the cards useful to another group of people, working jazz musicians. As a black art form, jazz had developed out of a mix of other black music traditions, including spirituals in the blues.
爵士乐手会围绕这些歌曲进行即兴演奏和自由发挥。这一直是爵士乐的关键部分，即即兴创作的艺术。但让普通的小号手或萨克斯手真正有价值的是他们能够当场演奏数百首歌曲中任何一首的能力。在20世纪40年代，人们作为音乐人稳定工作，在夜总会弹钢琴或在小乐队里演奏，满足听众的点歌需求。你知道，那个老套的桥段：一个醉汉在台下喊，“嘿，你能演奏《我爱旧金山》吗？”为了应对任何醉酒后的点歌，音乐家们会带上一大堆乐谱去参加每一场演出。但拖着一大堆纸真的很麻烦。这就是“曲库卡”派上用场的地方。
By the 40s, a lot of jazz was popular dance music, and many jazz musicians were making their money playing live gigs in small clubs and bars. The standard jazz repertoire was mostly well-known songs from Broadway or New York Songwriting Factory, Tin Pan Alley, like the song Night and Day by Tin Pan Alley Legend, Cole Porter. Cold Porter.
有人想出，你可以收集一堆“曲库卡”卡片，把它们复印在纸上，加上目录和简单的装订，然后直接以书的形式卖给音乐家。他们称之为“假书”，因为它们帮助音乐家在不熟悉的歌曲中“蒙混过关”（fake their way through）。这些早期的“假书”比普通的乐谱便宜，而且更有条理，它们成为了这一整类职业音乐家的必备工具。然后他们可以带着那本书去演出，而不必在成堆的乐谱中翻找，
Jazz musicians would riff and freestyle over these songs. That's always been a key part of jazz, the art of improvisation. But what made the average gigging trumpeter or sax player truly valuable was their ability to play any one of hundreds of songs right there on the spot. In the 1940s, people are working steadily as musicians, playing piano in nightclubs or playing in a small group in nightclubs, fulfilling requests. You know, the cliche of the drunken guy at the, hey, can you play, I love my art in San Francisco. To be prepared for any drunken request, musicians would bring stacks and stacks of sheet music to every gig. But lugging around a giant pile of paper was really cumbersome. And that's where the Toondex came in.
并试图保持每一张乐谱的字母顺序，那简直是噩梦。你有一本装订好的小书，里面有300首、500首或1000首曲子，那成了第一本流行的音乐“假书”。音乐家们喜欢这些新的“假书”，但音乐出版商却不这么认为。他们希望音乐家购买他们的乐谱，因此出版公司开始打击“假书”盗版商。
Someone figured out that you could gather a bunch of Toondex cards, print copies of them on sheets of paper, add a table of contents and a simple binding, and then sell the finished product directly to musicians in the form of a book. They called them fakebooks because they helped musicians fake their way through unfamiliar songs. These first fakebooks were cheaper than regular sheet music and a lot more organized, and they became an essential tool for this entire class of working musicians. And then they could bring that to gigs instead of having to trawl through piles of sheet music
音乐出版商竭尽所能，通过联邦调查局调查和联邦审判，试图压制这种新的音乐分发方式。但这并没有阻止盗版商。到了20世纪50年代，市面上出现了无数非法的“假书”，它们被全国各地的夜总会使用。但尽管“假书”很有用，它们也有很多问题。它们以难以辨认和排版混乱而闻名。
and try to keep each individual sheet in alphabetical order, what a nightmare. You have your bound little book of 300 tunes or 500 tunes or a thousand tunes, and that became the first popular music, fake book. Musicians loved these new fake books, but the music publishers, not so much. They wanted musicians to buy their sheet music, and so the publishing companies started cracking down on fake book bootleggers.
怎么强调旧版“假书”在这方面的缺陷都不为过。它们以难以辨认和排版混乱而闻名。史蒂夫·斯沃洛是一位爵士乐手，被认为是个很棒的人。我是一名贝斯手，我也写曲子。这是我生命中最突出的事实。作为20世纪50年代的一名年轻爵士乐手，斯沃洛在俱乐部、舞会、婚礼和犹太成人礼上演奏。对于许多演出，他都依赖这些设计糟糕的“假书”。
The music publishers did everything they could, FBI investigations and federal trials, in order to suppress this new way of distributing music. But that didn't stop the bootleggers. And by the 1950s, there were countless illegal fake books in existence, which were being used in nightclubs all across the country. But as helpful as fake books were, they had a lot of problems. They were notoriously illegible and confusingly laid out.
认真从事爵士乐工作时，我做的第一件事就是买一本“假书”。它们简直令人恼火，写得一团糟。当时这些“假书”的另一个大问题是里面的音乐感觉非常过时。“假书”自40年代中期以来就没有变过，但爵士乐却变了。对迎合主流白人听众的商业爵士乐感到幻灭，新一代黑人音乐家将爵士即兴创作提升到了一个新的水平，尝试更尖锐的和声、
It can't be stressed enough how deficient the old fake books were in this regard, problems. They were notoriously illegible and confusingly laid out. Steve Swallow is a jazz musician and thought of as a swell guy. I'm a bass player and I write tunes. That's the salient fact of my life. Starting off as a young jazz musician in the 1950s, Swallow played at clubs and dances and weddings and bar mitzvahs. And for a lot of these gigs, he relied on these poorly designed fake books.
技术要求极高的旋律和快得惊人的节奏。他们的新风格被称为“比波普”（bebop）。这种风格被称为“比波普”。那是比波普传奇查理·帕克。而“比波普”仅仅是个开始。接着是“硬波普”（hardbop）和迈尔斯·戴维斯领衔的“调式爵士”（modal jazz）。然后是奥内特·科尔曼等人狂野、不和谐的“自由爵士”（free jazz）。以及赫比·汉考克的电子爵士融合乐。到了20世纪70年代，爵士乐已经爆发成一系列不同的风格。
Working on jazz music seriously, one of the first things I did was to buy a fake book. And so we're just vexing and badly written. The other big problem with these fake books at this point was that the music inside felt really out of date. The fake books hadn't changed since the mid-40s, but jazz had. Disillusioned by commercial jazz that appealed to mainstream white audiences, a new generation of black musicians took jazz improvisation to a new level, experimenting with more angular harmonies,
与此同时，爵士乐的经济状况也发生了变化。俱乐部少了，报酬也少了。大学爵士乐课程也在这段时间开始涌现，为资深音乐家提供了稳定的教学工作。而且，“象牙塔”越来越多地成为年轻音乐家学习的地方。如果你要上爵士乐学校，你需要爵士乐书籍。但当时的“假书”并没有跟上音乐的发展。它们仍然包含着同样老式的标准曲集，有着同样老式的
technically demanding melodies, and blindingly fast tempos. Their new style was called bebop. The style was called bebop. That was bebop legend Charlie Parker. And bebop was just the beginning. Then came hardbop and modal jazz spearheaded by Miles Davis. Then you had the wild, dissonant free jazz of people like Ornette Coleman. And the electrified jazz fusion of Herbie Hancock. By the 1970s, jazz had exploded into this constellation of different styles.
和弦进行。所以，如果一个年轻的爵士乐手想尝试像查尔斯·明格斯或桑尼·罗林斯那样演奏，他们是无法从书中学到的。直到两个大学生发明了《真实之书》。我不想过分强调我在其中的作用，那很小。但我认识那几个人。70年代中期，史蒂夫·斯沃洛开始在波士顿的伯克利音乐学院任教，这是一所精英私立音乐学校，拥有全国首批爵士乐表演课程之一。
Meanwhile, the economics of jazz had shifted too. There were fewer clubs and smaller paychecks. University jazz programs also started popping up around this time, providing steady teaching gigs to established musicians. And increasingly, the Ivory Tower became a place for young musicians to learn. And if you're going to jazz school, you need jazz books. But the fake books at the time hadn't kept up with the music. They still contained the same old-fashioned collection of standards with the same old-fashioned
斯沃洛在伯克利教书才几个月，就有两名学生找到他，谈论一个秘密项目。我一直称他们为“写书的那两个人”，因为很久以前他们让我发誓保密。他们让我同意不泄露他们的名字。这两个人想制作一本新的“假书”，一本真正满足当代爵士乐手需求并反映爵士乐现状的书。他们需要史蒂夫的帮助。他们就是这样推销这个想法的。
collection of chord changes. So if a young jazz musician wanted to try and play like Charles Mingus or Sonny Rollins, they weren't going to learn from a book. That is, until two college kids invented the real book. I don't want to over-emphasize my role in it, which was minor. But I knew the guys. In the mid-70s, Steve Swallow began teaching at Boston's Berkeley College of Music, an elite private music school that boasted one of the first jazz performance programs in the country.
他们推销说，他们想写一本真正对一个想成为爵士乐手的18岁年轻人有用的“假书”。作为一些非常糟糕的“假书”的长期用户，史蒂夫很兴奋。他认为一本现代、制作精良的爵士“假书”对他的学生来说将是一个重要的改进。事实上，这也是我最初回应他们提议的一部分。我想，天哪，我怎么没想到呢？但他也很纠结。他知道学生们不可能为他们想收录的所有歌曲支付许可费。所以他必须决定帮助他们是否是正确的做法。因为很明显，他们的意图是违法。
Swallow had only been teaching at Berkeley for a few months when two students approached him about a secret project. I keep referring to them as the two guys who wrote the book because way back when they swore me to secrecy. They made me agree that I would not divulge their names. The two guys wanted to make a new fake book, one that actually catered to the needs of contemporary jazz musicians and reflected the current state of jazz. And they needed Steve's help. That's how they pitched it.
他们还将出售一本装满别人音乐的书。但最终，斯沃洛认为对一本好的爵士“假书”的需求如此之大，以至于这是值得的，于是他同意提供帮助。斯沃洛和学生们打算制作一本真正对试图演奏爵士乐的年轻人有用的“假书”。一本真正的书（A real book）。从一开始，学生们就设想《真实之书》是一本比他们从小接触的那些死板、过时的
They pitched it that they wanted to write a fake book that would actually be useful to an 18-year-old person who wanted to become a fake book that would actually be useful to an 18-year-old person who wanted to become a jazz musician. As a longtime user of some pretty horrible fake books, Steve was excited. He thought that a modern, well-made jazz fake book would be an essential improvement for his students. And indeed, that was part of my initial response to their pitch. I thought, Jesus, why didn't I think of this? But he was also torn. He knew the students couldn't possibly pay licensing fees for all the songs they wanted to include. So he had to decide whether helping them was the right thing to do. Because clearly their intention was to break the law.
“假书”更酷、更现代的书。他们想收录现代爵士乐手创作的新歌，这些乐手正在推动该流派的边界。他们还想收录来自百老汇和廷潘巷的老爵士标准曲，但他们想用反映迈尔斯·戴维斯等现代音乐家实际演奏方式的替代和弦进行来更新这些经典。迈尔斯·戴维斯是这一切的核心人物，他可以说挖掘了数十首廷潘巷的曲子。他和他的伴奏乐手，特别是他的钢琴家，以一种成为定论的方式平滑了和声。
They would also be selling a book filled with other people's music. But in the end, Swallow decided that the need for a good jazz fakebook was so great that it was worth it, and he agreed to help. Swallow and the students were going to make a fakebook that would actually be useful to a young person trying to play jazz. A real fakebook. A real book. From the very beginning, the students envisioned the real book as a cooler and more contemporary
其中一首标准曲是《总有一天我的王子会来》（Someday My Prince Will Come），这是1937年迪士尼音乐电影《白雪公主》中的一首歌。这是原版。这是迈尔斯·戴维斯1961年的版本，也就是学生们决定收录进《真实之书》的版本。这是同一首歌，但听听当钢琴家温顿·凯利演奏时，和弦听起来有多么不同、多么复杂。多年来，现代爵士乐手以这种方式改变了许多经典标准曲。为了捕捉这些复杂的替代和弦进行，这两名学生花了数小时听录音并转录他们听到的内容。
fakebook than the stagy, outdated ones they'd grown up with. They wanted to include new songs from modern jazz musicians who were pushing the boundaries of the genre. They also wanted to include the old jazz standards from Broadway and Tin Pan Alley, but they wanted to update those classics with alternate chord changes that reflected the way that modern musicians like Miles Davis were actually playing them. Miles Davis was a central figure in all of this and he kind of exhumed dozens, I would say, of Tin Pan Alley tunes. And he and his sidemen, notably his pianists, had smoothed the harmonies in a way that became definitive.
尽他们所能。这是一项巨大的工程，因为这些和弦进行中的大多数实际上从未被写下来过。他们当时并不一定是以这种方式思考的，但学生们实际上是在为少数几首经典歌曲建立一套新的标准化和声。但音乐并不是这两名学生想改进的新“假书”的唯一部分。他们还想解决旧“假书”的美学问题，制作出看起来美观且易于阅读的东西。其中一个人有一手漂亮的乐谱字迹，他书写四分音符和八分音符的方式等等。非常可爱。
One of those standard tunes is, Someday My Prince Will Come, a song from the 1937 Disney movie musical Snow White. Here's the original. And here's the Miles Davis version from 1961, the version that the students decided to put in the real book. It's the same song, but listen to how different, how complex the chords sound when played by pianist Wynton Kelly. Modern jazz musicians had altered a lot of classic standards in this way over the years. And to capture these sophisticated alternate chord changes, the two students spent hours listening to recordings and transcribing what they heard.
他在书中的角色，除其他事项外，是他完成了所有实际的笔迹工作。是一个人写了整本书。他用这种非常独特且富有表现力的字体手写了所有的音乐。他还设计并丝网印刷了封面上的标志，只是“The Real Book”这几个字，用粗犷的“学校摇滚”（Schoolhouse Rock）风格的块状字母书写。把一切固定在一起的是一种塑料装订，让书可以很容易地平放在乐谱架上。到1975年夏天，这本书完成了，
As best they could. It was a huge undertaking because most of these chord changes had never actually been written down. They weren't necessarily thinking about it like this at the time, but the students were effectively establishing a new set of standardized harmonies for a handful of classic songs. But the music wasn't the only part of their new fake book that the two students wanted to improve. They also wanted to fix the aesthetic problems with the old fake books and make something that was nice to look at and easy to read. One of the two guys had a gorgeous music hand the way he formed his quarter notes and his eighth notes and all of that. It was lovely.
学生们把它带到当地的复印店，在那里他们印制了数百份，直接卖给其他学生和伯克利附近的一些当地企业。有一家叫“本特利烟草店”（Bentley Smoker）的街角商店，那不是一家音乐店。只是每个人都抽烟，那是一家香烟店，柜台下面就堆着一摞《真实之书》。几乎一夜之间，每个人都必须拥有一本。
And his role in the book, among other things, he did all the actual penmanship. It's one guy who wrote the entire book. He notated all of the music by hand in this very distinctive and expressive script. He also designed and silkscreened the logo on the front cover, just the words, the real book, written in chunky, schoolhouse rock style block letters. And holding everything together was a plastic binding that let the book easily lie flat on a music stand. By the summer of 1975, the book was done
包括我的老爵士乐老师伦纳德先生，他从马萨诸塞大道上那个留长发的家伙那里买了一本《真实之书》。在马萨诸塞大道上，我想是20美元，在那时这很贵。当时的感觉是，哇，好吧，但这就是你所需要的。就像买教科书一样。事实上，我用它的次数比我的一些课本或教室里的教材还要多。他主要是在练习室的深夜即兴演奏会上和其他学生一起使用它。任何人都可以进去演奏，当然，因为这是一所
and the students took it to local photocopying shops where they cranked out hundreds of copies to sell directly to other students and a few local businesses near Berkeley. There was a corner store called the Bentley Smoker, which was not a music shop. It was just everybody smoked and it was a cigarette store and beneath the counter was a stack of real books. And almost overnight everybody had to have one.
大学校，所以人很多。如果你带着你的书走进去，你就可以参与其中。伦纳德先生说，《真实之书》帮助每个人很快地达成共识，史蒂夫·斯沃洛也注意到了这一点。在《真实之书》问世之前，他经常走过练习室，听到学生们把所有这些爵士乐曲的和弦进行弹得一团糟。突然间，《真实之书》出现了，我走过同样的路，听到《我爱你》（I Love You）和《我可笑的情人节》（My Funny Valentine）正确的和弦。
Including my old jazz teacher, Mr. Leonard, he bought a copy of the real book from that guy with the long hair on Mass Ave. On Mass Ave, I think it was 2020, which was steep at that point. It was like, wow, okay, but that's what you needed. It was like buying a schoolbook. In fact, I used it more than some of my textbooks or classrooms. Mainly he used it with other students in late night jam sessions in the practice rooms. Anybody could go in and play, and of course there were a lot of them because it was a
哇，这太了不起了。《真实之书》的名声越来越大，需求也随之增加。那两名学生印的数量不足以满足需求。但事实证明，他们不需要这样做。在他们出版了（你知道，几百份复印版）这本书后不久，其他人就复印了这本书并开始销售。然后这些复印件的复印件传到了纽约市和洛杉矶，然后传到了柏林、上海等等。传到了纽约市和洛杉矶，然后传到了柏林、上海等等。《真实之书》有了自己的生命，而学生们讽刺地发现自己处于与他们最初排除在过程之外的音乐出版商和词曲作者相同的境地，
big school. And if you walked in with your book, you could participate and be a part of it. Mr. Leonard says the real book helped everyone get on the same page really quickly and Steve Swallow noticed this too. Before the real book came out he used to walk by the practice rooms and hear students mangling the chord changes to all of these jazz tunes. And all of a sudden the re-book came along and I was making this same walk and hearing the right changes to, I love you, and the right changes to my funny Valentine's.
因为他们看着自己作品的未经授权的副本被复制和出售。当然，他们也没立场去抱怨。他们只能摇摇头。在发行了《真实之书》第一版后，学生们又推出了两个版本来纠正错误，然后他们的工作就完成了。但《真实之书》继续存在，被一代又一代的盗版商反复复制。
Whoa, this is remarkable. As the real book's notoriety grew, so did the demand. The two students hadn't printed enough copies to keep up. But it turns out they didn't need to. Not long after they published, you know, a few hundred photocopied versions of this book, somebody else photocopied the book and started selling it. And then copies of the copies were fanning out to New York City and LA and then beyond to Berlin and Shanghai and so on. to New York City and LA and then beyond to Berlin and Shanghai and so on. The real book had taken on a life of its own, and the students ironically found themselves in the same position as the music publishers and songwriters that they'd originally cut
史蒂夫·斯沃洛并不轻视版权问题，但他认为《真实之书》对收录其中的作曲家来说是一个净收益，而且他很清楚这一点，因为他就是其中之一。当他同意帮助学生时，斯沃洛实际上捐赠了他自己的许多歌曲。他认为，如果更多的年轻人接触到他的音乐，从长远来看对他是有利的。他们甚至可能在某天录制翻唱版本，这将为他带来版税。平心而论，《真实之书》确实是我了解史蒂夫·斯沃洛的方式。我想直到今天，我的歌之所以被演奏，主要是因为
out of the process as they watched unlicensed copies of their work get duplicated and sold. And of course they were in no position to yell about. They kind of had to just shake their heads. After they released the first edition of The Real Book, the students put out two more additions to correct mistakes, and then their work was done. But The Real Book lived on, copied over and over again by new generations of bootleggers.
它们在《真实之书》中可以找到。这是一种福气。随着精英音乐学院爵士乐课程的学生人数在接下来的几十年里持续膨胀，《真实之书》凭借其现代曲目、重新编配的标准曲和优美的笔迹，成为了这支新爵士乐学生大军的事实教科书，爵士乐的非官方官方手册。就像旧的“假书”一样，《真实之书》的成功对音乐
Steve Swallow doesn't take the copyright issue lightly, but he thinks the real book was a net positive for the composers featured inside, and he would know since he's one of them. When he agreed to help the students, Swallow actually donated a bunch of his own songs. He figured it would benefit him in the long run if more young people were exposed to his music. They might even record a cover someday, which would bring him royalties. And to be fair, the real book is actually how I learned who Steve Swallow was. I think to this day my songs are played to the extent that they are, chiefly because
出版商来说是一个大问题。一些公司发行了自己的爵士乐歌集，但他们从未能与《真实之书》竞争。它无法与《真实之书》竞争，因为它就是没有收录所有正确的歌曲。这是杰夫·施拉德。他是印刷音乐出版公司哈尔·伦纳德（Hal Leonard）的高管。你知道，《真实之书》是非法的，所以他们不在乎许可，他们只是把所有最好的歌都放进去，而且不付钱给任何人，这并不是正确的做法。但显然从竞争的角度来看，他们一上来就拥有了最好的书。
they were available in the real book. It's been a blessing. And as the number of students in elite conservatory jazz programs continued to swell over the next few decades, the real book, with its modern repertoire, reharmonized standards, and beautiful handwriting, became the de facto textbook for this new legion of jazz students, the unofficial official handbook of jazz. Just like with old fake books, the success of The Real Book was a major problem for music
《真实之书》的流行意味着很多人没有因为他们的工作得到报酬。直到杰夫·施拉德决定制作一个合法版本。真正的《真实之书》。决定制作一个合法版本。真正的《真实之书》。你知道，我说，嘿，我们出版爵士“假书”、爵士主旋律谱和各种爵士出版物。而且，你知道，然而《真实之书》仍然是那本书。而且，你知道，为什么我们不合法地出版《真实之书》呢？2000年代中期，杰夫·施拉德和出版商哈尔·伦纳德获得了《真实之书》中几乎每首歌的版权，并出版了一个完全合法的版本。
publishers. Some companies released their own jazz songbooks, but they never managed to compete with The Real Book. It couldn't compete with The Real Book because it just didn't have all the right songs in it. This is Jeff Schradle. He's an executive at Hal Leonard, a print music publishing company. You know, The Real Book was illegal, so they didn't care about licensing and they just put all the best songs in and didn't pay anyone, which wasn't the right thing to do. But obviously from a competitive standpoint, they had the best book out of the gate.
你不再需要从别人的汽车后备箱里买《真实之书》了。它在当地的乐器店就能买到。对我来说，这个新版本最引人注目的是它的外观。我们不想制作哈尔·伦纳德公司版的《真实之书》。我们想保持那种手工制作的地下外观。我们想要同样的卡纸。我们想要同样的标志。我们想要同样的装订。
And the popularity of the real book meant that lots of people weren't getting paid for their work. That is, until Jeff Schradle decided to make a legal version. The real, real book. decided to make a legal version. The Real Real Book. You know, I said, hey, we published jazz fake books and jazz lead sheets and jazz publications of all kinds. And, you know, yet the real book is still the book. And, you know, why don't we just publish the real book legally? In the mid-2000s, Jeff Schradle and the publisher Hal Leonard secured the rights to almost every song in the real book and published a completely legal version.
他们甚至想要同样的笔迹。哈尔·伦纳德实际上雇佣了一名抄谱员来模仿旧版《真实之书》标志性的字体，并将其转化为数字字体，这意味着一位匿名伯克利学生在70年代中期的手写体的数字副本，只要这本书的新版本继续出版，就会一直存在下去。当哈尔·伦纳德在2004年最终出版了《真实之书》的合法版本时，如果你是一位收录了歌曲的作曲家，这真是个好消息。你终于可以从世界上最受欢迎的爵士乐书籍的销售中获得版税了。
You don't need to buy the real book out of the back of someone's car anymore. It's available at your local music shop. And to me, the striking thing about this new version is the way that it looks. We didn't want to make the Hal Leonard corporate real book. We wanted to maintain that sort of homespun underground look. We wanted the same card stock. We wanted the same logo. We wanted the same binding.
但这并没有完全解决《真实之书》的知识产权问题。为了理解为什么不，我们将看看里面的一首歌。它叫《精致女士》（Sophisticated Lady），在哈尔·伦纳德版《真实之书》的第376页。《精致女士》最早由传奇钢琴家艾灵顿公爵和他的乐队在1933年录制。艾灵顿乐队的一位长号手名叫劳伦斯·布朗，他有一个他喜欢演奏的标志性即兴乐句。如果你听《精致女士》的开头，你会听到它。那是旋律。
And they even wanted the same handwriting. Hal Leonard actually hired a copyist to mimic the old real book's iconic script and turn it into a digital font, which means a digital copy of a physical copy of one anonymous Berkeley students handwriting from the mid-70s will continue to live on for as long as new editions of the book are published. When Hal Leonard finally published the legal version of the real book in 2004, it was great news if you were a composer with a song in there. You'd finally be getting royalties from the sale of the most popular book of jazz
这是劳伦斯·布朗与记者帕特里夏·威拉德的谈话。但主要是，我有一个我一直演奏的主题，也就是前八小节。那是《精致女士》的基本曲调。但据布朗说，艾灵顿为他对这首歌的贡献付给了他15美元。我收到了一张15美元的支票，作为《精致女士》的报酬。啊。现在呢？你有没有获得过联合作曲家的署名？没有。没有，那张支票就把你打发了。
music in the world. But that didn't totally solve the intellectual property problems with the real book. And to understand why not, we're going to take a look at one of the songs inside. It's called Sophisticated Lady, and it's on page 376 of the Hal Leonard real book. Sophisticated Lady was first recorded by the legendary pianist Duke Ellington and his band in 1933. A trombonist in Ellington's band named Lawrence Brown had this signature riff that he liked to play. And if you listen to the beginning of Sophisticated Lady, you'll hear it. It's the melody.
这意味着布朗在法律上没有资格获得词曲作者署名或版税，尽管他贡献了这首歌最易辨认的元素之一。我想这很划算，不是吗？是的。这就是音乐。但布朗认为，如果没有他的标志性旋律，《精致女士》甚至不会存在，而艾灵顿却因为写了一首他仅仅是编曲的歌而获得了荣誉。你的旋律，而艾灵顿却因为写了一首他仅仅是编曲的歌而获得了荣誉。
Here's Lawrence Brown talking with journalist Patricia Willard. But mainly I had a theme that I played all the time, which is the first eight bars. That was the basic tune of Sophisticated Lady. But according to Brown, Ellington paid him $15 for his contribution to the song. And I got the terrific check for $15 for a place for a righty-bisplicated lady. Ah. Now? Have you ever gotten co-composer credit? No. No, that check cancels you out.
讽刺的是，确实在《精致女士》上获得联合创作署名的一个人是艾灵顿公爵的白人经理欧文·米尔斯。米尔斯到底贡献了什么是有争议的，但很明显，他利用自己的权力让自己的名字出现在艾灵顿的许多歌曲上，并为自己获取更多的版税。直到今天，当你打开哈尔·伦纳德版《真实之书》翻到《精致女士》时，你会看到列出的三位作者，包括艾灵顿公爵和欧文·米尔斯。但你不会看到的一个名字是劳伦斯·布朗。因此，虽然《真实之书》的合法化确实解决了它大部分公然的版权侵权行为，但它并没有理清像这样可以追溯到爵士乐早期的署名权纠纷。而且很可能还有许多像布朗一样的音乐家，他们的名字永远不会出现在他们帮助创作的歌曲上，即使这些歌曲出现在合法的《真实之书》中。即使我们把知识产权问题放在一边，
That means that Brown wasn't legally entitled to a songwriter credit or royalties, even though he contributed one of the song's most recognizable elements. I thought it was quite a bargain, wasn't it? Yeah. That's music. But Brown thought that sophisticated Lady wouldn't even exist without his signature melody, and that Ellington took credit for writing a song that he merely arranged. your melody, and that Ellington took credit for writing a song that he merely arranged.
片刻之后，《真实之书》仍然有很多批评者。《真实之书》，那些家伙，当他们做的时候，他们转录了东西，他们选择了有些人正在使用的标准和弦，但并不是每个人都在使用那些相同的和弦。卡罗琳·威尔金斯在伯克利音乐学院教授合奏，她说《真实之书》多年来变得如此受欢迎，以至于人们开始把里面的歌曲版本视为定论。但尽管爵士乐有所有这些标准曲，威尔金斯说它们并不是
Ironically, one person who did get co-writing credits on Sophisticated Lady was Duke Ellington's white manager Irving Mills. What exactly Mills contributed is debated, but it's clear that he used his power to get his name on many of Ellington's songs and reap more royalties for himself. To this day, when you open up the Howl Leonard real book and turn to Sophisticated Lady, you'll see three listed writers, including Duke Ellington and Irving Mills. But one name you won't see is Lawrence Brown. And so while the legalization of the real book did resolve most of its flagrant copyright violations, it didn't clear up authorship disputes like these that go back to the early days of jazz. And there are likely many more musicians, just like Brown, whose names will never appear on the songs they helped write, even if those songs appear in the legal real book. Even if we put intellectual property questions aside
应该以一种标准方式演奏的。人们，特别是在过去，认为在某样东西上打上自己的原创印记远比演奏得“正确”重要得多。所以他们可能会在这里改一个和弦，可能会改一个音符，他们可能会决定他们更喜欢降D大调而不是降D大调。这种即兴创作在过去两个世纪的古典音乐中要少见得多，在古典音乐中，真实性更多地在于你能多精确地再现页面上的内容。当人们演奏莫扎特的《C大调第16号钢琴奏鸣曲》时，他们不会说，你知道吗，这次我要尝试用A大调演奏。
for a second, the real book still has plenty of critics. The real book, the guys, when they did it, they transcribed things and they chose standard chords that some people were using, but not everyone was using those same chords. Carolyn Wilkins teaches ensembles at Berkeley College of Music, and she says that the real book got so popular over the years that people started to treat the versions of the songs inside as definitive. But even though jazz has all these standards, Wilkins says they're not
所以当音乐家演奏一个听起来和《真实之书》中完全一样的《再见黑鸟》（Bye Bye Blackbird）版本时，他们的行为更像古典音乐家而不是爵士乐手。一旦事情在《真实之书》中标准化了，你就会遇到这种情况：人们总是以同样的方式、同样的调性、同样的一套和弦进行来演奏同样的东西。尼古拉斯·佩顿是一位音乐家和唱片公司老板，他把《真实之书》比作学习指南或小抄，基本上是一种将这种复杂的艺术形式提炼成可消化的、易于管理的
supposed to be played in one standard way. People, especially back in the day, considered putting their original stamp on something to be far more important than playing it, quote, unquote, correctly. So they might change a chord here, they might change a note, they might decide they like the key of D-flat better than the key of D-flat. This type of improvisation is much less common in classical music from the last two centuries, where authenticity is more about how well you can reproduce what's on the page as precisely as possible. When people play Mozart's piano sonata number 16 and C major, they don't say, you know what, I'm going to try it in A major this time.
信息包的方法。但是，你看，当你谈论编纂和教授黑人音乐时，问题就来了，因为你无法教授自由的节奏思维。你不能把它写进书里，并期望学生能领会它。对佩顿来说，音乐不仅仅是可以从书中学习的信息。它是一种思维方式和一种表达形式。它从根本上是一种黑人文化现象，不能脱离其历史背景。它本质上是一种公共音乐，是一个活生生的、会呼吸的有机体。
And so when musicians play a version of Bye Bye Blackbird that sounds exactly as it appears in the real book, they're acting more like classical musicians than jazz musicians. And once things kind of became standardized into the real book, then you have this thing of people who just always play the same thing the same way, same key, same set of chord changes. Nicholas Payton is a musician and record label owner, and he compares the real book to a study guide or a cheat sheet, basically a way to distill this complicated art form into a manageable packet of digestible
它不能以那种方式被收藏或存档。佩顿说，阅读像《真实之书》这样的书，甚至去音乐学校，真正能带你走的路是有限的。在某个时候，你必须让自己沉浸在音乐文化中。对于佩顿和许多其他音乐家来说，直接向长辈当面学习是真正了解这种艺术形式的意义的关键部分。我想对于许多可能不住在底特律、纽约、新奥尔良或芝加哥这样繁荣的音乐文化中的人来说，如果你住在爱荷华州的得梅因，你知道，学校
information. But, you see, here becomes a problem when you're talking about codifying and teaching black music, is you can't teach free rhythmic thought. You can't put that in a book and expect students to grasp it. To Peyton, the music isn't just information to be learned from a book. It's a way of thinking and a form of expression. And it's fundamentally a black cultural phenomenon that can't be taken out of its historical context. It's a communal music at its essence and it's a living, breathing organism.
可能是一个很好的资源和工具。但最终在某个时候，如果你是认真想演奏这种音乐，你必须和那些真正演奏它的人在一起。但卡罗琳·威尔金斯说，《真实之书》在爵士乐教育中确实有一席之地。在伯克利任教的这些年里，她看到了它如何成为一个有用的起点，一个将年轻爵士乐手聚集在一起的工具。一本传统的《真实之书》至少让你对“这就是曲目”有了一些概念。这些就是曲子。如果你想走进世界任何地方的即兴演奏会，拿出你的乐器说，
It can't be housed or archived in that way. Peyton says that reading books like The Real Book, even going to music school, can only really get you so far. At some point, you're going to have to immerse yourself in the culture of the music. For Peyton and many other musicians, learning directly from elders in person is a crucial part of what it means to really know the art form. I think for many people who perhaps don't live in a thriving music culture like a Detroit or New York or New Orleans or Chicago, if you live in Des Moines, Iowa, you know, school
我可以加入吗？这些就是你需要知道的曲子。如果你说，好吧，我们要演奏《美丽的爱》（Beautiful Love），砰。现在每个人都有一本《真实之书》，那是D小调的《美丽的爱》。我们准备好了。但她也说，如果你只演奏《真实之书》中记谱的歌曲，而这就是你所做的全部，你并没有真正以它应该被演奏的方式演奏音乐。要做到这一点，你必须走得更远。然后你出去听20个不同的人演奏它，找到不同的方式，最终你必须找到你自己的方式。休息之后，米歇尔和我将讨论《真实之书》的核心谜团。
might be a good resource and tool. But eventually at some point, if you're serious about playing this music, you're going to have to be around people who actually do it. But Carolyn Wilkins says that the real book does have its place in jazz education. Over her years at Berkeley, she's seen how it can be a useful starting place, a tool to bring young jazz musicians together. A traditional real book gives you at least some sense of this is the repertoire. These are the tunes. If you wanna walk into a jam session anywhere in the world and unpack your instrument and say,
是谁编译了第一个版本并在波士顿周围出售的那两名伯克利学生？休息之后，我们将深入探讨这个兔子洞。好的。好的，我们回到报道那个故事的米哈伊尔·马卡瓦诺。米哈伊尔，据我所知，这个故事的核心有一个核心谜团。那就是谁写了《真实之书》，第一本《真实之书》。作者的身份多年来一直保持匿名。但你决心试图弄清楚这一点。那么你为什么要了解作者的身份呢？所以《真实之书》在我学习爵士乐时，你知道，在高中，是一种无处不在的东西，
can I sit in, these are the tunes that you're going to need. And if you say, all right, we're going to play beautiful love, boom. Now everyone has a real book that there's beautiful love D minor. We're ready. But she also says if you only play songs as they're notated in the real book, and that's as far as you take it, you're not really playing the music the way it's supposed to be played. To do that, you have to go further. Then you go out and listen to 20 different people play it and find different ways and then ultimately you must find your own way. After the break, Michele and I talk about the central mystery of the real book.
它甚至看起来不像是有作者。它只是感觉像是一本每个人都有的书，你知道，凭空冒出来的。所以当我得知有这个背景故事，并且在《真实之书》背后有这些神秘人物时，我就想，我必须知道。对我来说，部分原因也确实是，《真实之书》对我高中学习爵士乐的方法产生了很大的影响，那些把它放在一起的人，他们所做的选择在某种程度上指导了我正在做的事情，就像这种无形的手，你知道，引导着我的音乐发展。所以试图去接触并找到那些人，对我来说有一种奇怪的意义。
Who were the two Berkley students who compiled the first version and sold it around Boston? We go down that rabbit hole after this. Okay. Okay, so we're back with Mikhail Makavanaugh, who reported that story. And Mikhail, as I understand it, there is a central mystery at the heart of this story. And that's who wrote the real book, the first real book. The identities of the authors have remained anonymous after all these years. But you were determined to try to figure this out. So why did you want to know the identity of the authors? So the real book was just this kind of omnipresent thing when I was, you know, learning jazz in high school,
这对我来说很有道理。那么，好的，你从哪里开始的？所以我首先和我的高中爵士乐老师伦纳德先生谈了谈，他在70年代末是伯克利的大学生，在《真实之书》问世几年后。但他告诉我，你知道，当他在那里读书时，没有人真正对《真实之书》背后的故事或它来自哪里感兴趣。不，在那个时候，我们只关心尽量不要因为从
and it didn't even really seem like it had authors to begin with. It just felt like this book that everybody had, and know just popped out of thin air and so when I learned that there was this backstory and there were these people kind of mysterious figures behind the real book I was just like I have to know part of it too for me was really just you know the real book had a big impact on my approach to learning jazz in high school and the guys who put it together the choices that they made kind of directed what I was doing, the kind of like this invisible hand, you know, guiding my musical development. And so to kind of try and reach out and find those guys felt weirdly meaningful to me in
拐角处的那个家伙那里买它而被抓。我甚至不记得它是一个讨论的话题。好的，所以伦纳德先生是个死胡同，那么你接下来转向了谁？所以我接下来和史蒂夫·斯沃洛谈了谈，史蒂夫·斯沃洛非常深入地参与了这本书的创作。显然他知道这些人是谁，但他并不打算告诉我，因为他们在完成并出版后让他发誓保密。但尽管如此，你知道，我问他，你有他们的联系方式吗？如果你有的话，你能代表我联系他们吗？他说，是的，我想我可能在10年前通过电子邮件和其中一个人联系过。
a way. That makes sense to me. So, okay, so where did you start? So I started by talking to my high school jazz teacher, Mr. Leonard, who was a student at Berkeley in the late 70s, a couple of years after the real book came out. But he told me that, you know, when he was a student there, no one was really interested in the story behind the real book or where it came from. No, at that point, we were just concerned with trying not to get busted buying it from
我们可能在10年前有过电子邮件联系，但我会试试。我会给那个地址发一封电子邮件。如果它还能用，看看他怎么说，当然。好的，我们开始吧，好的。于是他发了，然后它回来了，你知道，退回给发件人，立即弹回。所以那也是一个死胡同。好的，好的。
the guy in the corner. I don't even remember it being much of a topic of discussion. Okay, so Mr. Leonard is a bust, so where did you turn to next? So next I talked to Steve Swallow, and Steve Swallow was pretty intimately involved in the creation of the book. And obviously he knew who these guys were, but he wasn't about to tell me because they had sworn him to a note of secrecy after they finished and put it out. But still, you know, I asked him, do you have their contact information? Would you be able to reach out on my behalf if you do? And he said, yeah, I think I was in touch with one of them via email maybe like 10 years
是的，在这一点上，我感到有点沮丧，有点卡住了，真的不知道接下来该做什么。然后，你知道，我开始在网上阅读任何人写过的关于《真实之书》的所有内容。有一天，我在互联网上某个随机的博客文章上，我向下滚动到评论区。第一条评论来自一个声称是原始作者之一的家伙。他说，你知道，我是《真实之书》的作者之一，他只用了一个字母。所以没有真实姓名。他只留下了一个字母来签署这条评论，那个字母是B。
ago. We've had email contact maybe Jesus, maybe 10 years ago, but I would try. I would send an email to that address. And if it still works, see what he says, sure. Okay, here we go, all right. And so he did, and it came back, you know, returned to sender, just bouncing back immediately. So that was also a dead end. Okay, okay.
以前。我们可能在天哪，大概十年前有过邮件联系，但我还是想试试。我会往那个地址发封邮件。如果还能用，看看他怎么说，当然。好的，开始了，好吧。于是他发了，结果被退回了，你知道的，退回给发件人，直接被弹回来了。所以那也是条死胡同。好吧，好吧。
Yeah, at this point, I'm feeling a little bit frustrated, a little bit stuck, not really sure what to do next. And then, you know, I just start reading everything I can online that anyone has written about the real book. And one day I'm on this random blog post somewhere on the internet, and I scroll down to the comments section. And one of the first comments is from a guy who's claiming to be one of the original authors. He's saying, you know, I was one of the authors of the real book and he only goes by one letter. So no real name. He leaves just a letter to sign off on this comment and the letter is B.
是的，到了这一步，我感到有点沮丧，有点卡住了，真的不知道接下来该怎么办。然后，你知道，我开始阅读网上任何人写的关于《Real Book》的所有内容。有一天，我在互联网上某个随机的博客文章里，我向下滚动到评论区。其中第一条评论来自一个自称是原始作者之一的人。他说，你知道，我是《Real Book》的作者之一，而且他只用了一个字母作为代号。所以没有真实姓名。他在评论结尾只留下了一个字母作为签名，那个字母是B。
So mysterious, very mysterious. This B guy, he also says he was in touch with Barry Kernfeld, who is a musicologist who I had actually already interviewed for this piece. Okay, okay. So how do you know that the person who wrote this comment was the person who actually wrote the real book and not just somebody claiming to be? Because I could go on a message board and say, I wrote the real book too, you know. Yeah, totally. So I actually reached out to Barry Kernfeld again after I'd interviewed him and I asked, is this legit? Did you get an email from this guy? Were you in contact with him? This guy who said he was in contact with you who claims to have written the real book and Barry said, yeah. Oh, okay.
太神秘了，非常神秘。这个B先生，他还说他曾与Barry Kernfeld联系过，Barry是一位音乐学家，我实际上已经为这篇文章采访过他了。好吧，好吧。那么你怎么知道写这条评论的人就是真正写那本书的人，而不是随便冒充的人呢？因为我也可以在留言板上说，我也写了那本真正的书，你知道的。是的，完全同意。所以我实际上在采访Barry Kernfeld之后又联系了他，我问他，这是真的吗？你收到过这个人的邮件吗？你们联系过吗？就是这个声称联系过你并自称写了那本真书的人，Barry说，是的。哦，好吧。
He said actually about ten years ago he got the email from this guy and you know that they were in contact and He said he actually still had that email and so I had to ask him obviously can you get back in touch? Can you email this guy again? And he said, sure, I'll try it's been a long time but I'll give it a shot. So Barry reached out to this guy a couple days later. He tells me to reach out directly. Okay, here we go.
他说其实大约十年前他收到过这个人的邮件，你知道他们确实联系过，他说他其实还保留着那封邮件，所以我显然不得不问他，你能再联系上他吗？你能再给这个人发邮件吗？他说，当然，我会试试，虽然已经过去很久了，但我会试一试。于是Barry在几天后联系了这个人。他让我直接联系他。好吧，我们开始吧。
I reach out and then a couple of days later, I hear back and it's a message from a ultra encrypted email server based somewhere outside of the United States. And it's someone using an obviously fake name, but it is definitely this guy. It is B. So this is the guy. I mean, this is the guy.
我联系了他，几天后，我收到了回复，那是一条来自美国境外某个地方的超加密电子邮件服务器的消息。发件人使用的是一个明显的假名，但绝对是这个人。就是B。所以这就是那个人。我的意思是，这就是那个人。
Is this, I mean, when you're going through this, is this level of subterfuge, does it feel necessary or theatrical, or how is it striking you at this point? It feels a little bit over the top. You know, I do feel like I'm corresponding with, you know, like a double agent, you know, deep in the cold war somewhere.
这是，我的意思是，当你经历这一切时，这种程度的隐秘行为，你觉得是必要的还是戏剧性的，或者说此时此刻你有什么感觉？感觉有点夸张了。你知道，我确实感觉自己像是在和一个深陷冷战某处的双重间谍通信。
But it's also a little bit exciting, kind of. It's not a huge mystery, but it is mysterious, definitely. So what did this email say? So I asked him if he would want to do an audio interview and predictably he said no. Then I asked him, do you want to answer a couple of questions over email? And he said, sure.
但这也有点令人兴奋，某种程度上。这不是什么惊天大秘密，但绝对很神秘。那么这封邮件说了什么？所以我问他是否愿意接受音频采访，不出所料，他拒绝了。然后我问他，你愿意通过电子邮件回答几个问题吗？他说，当然。
And so I sent him an email with a list of questions and waited a couple days, heard nothing back, sent a follow-up email, waited a couple more days, heard nothing back, sent another follow-up email. And then this continued four or five times. And at this point, I just kind of resigned myself to the fact that I was not going to hear back from him. Yeah. yeah, that's too bad. And I just started pursuing different avenues to try and find this guy or one of the guys.
于是我给他发了一封包含一系列问题的邮件，等了几天，没有回音，又发了一封跟进邮件，又等了几天，还是没有回音，又发了一封跟进邮件。这种情况持续了四五次。到了这个时候，我基本上已经接受了不会收到他回复的事实。是的，太遗憾了。我开始寻找不同的途径来尝试找到这个人，或者这些人中的某一个。
I asked my high school jazz teacher again, do you know people from Berkeley? Do you know some names? Can you put me in touch with them? And he got in touch with a teacher of his who passed on some names to me and I started emailing people, not getting any more responses.
我再次问我的高中爵士乐老师，你认识伯克利的人吗？你认识一些名字吗？你能帮我联系他们吗？他联系了他的一位老师，那位老师传给我一些名字，我开始给这些人发邮件，但没有得到任何回复。
I felt like I was kind of circling the drain at this point. And were you pretty resolved at this point that you were never going to hear from this person or find them before we put the story out? Yeah, I was like, we're never going to hear back. I was so close and we lost the thread. It's not coming back. So where are we now? Well, four days before this episode was set to air, I opened my email.
我觉得自己当时已经走投无路了。在你把这个故事发布之前，你是否已经下定决心永远不会收到这个人的回复或找到他们了？是的，我想，我们永远不会收到回复了。我离真相那么近，却失去了线索。它不会再回来了。那么我们现在在哪里？好吧，在这个节目播出前四天，我打开了我的邮箱。
It's about 10 p.m. I'm ready to go to sleep. And it's an email from B. Yes. With answers to all of our questions. Nice. So what did they have to say for themselves? Like what kind of questions did you ask?
大约晚上10点。我准备睡觉了。那是B发来的一封邮件。是的。回答了我们所有的问题。太棒了。那么他们对自己说了些什么？比如你问了什么样的问题？
So we asked kind of the gamut really of everything related to, you know, from handwriting, you know, was it his handwriting, how did he feel about that handwriting being, you know, omnipresent in real books throughout the world to like, how did it feel to create this thing that some people have, you know, major beefs or major problems with in terms of how it's affected jazz?
我们问了各种各样的问题，真的，所有相关的问题，从笔迹，你知道，那是他的笔迹吗，他对于自己的笔迹在世界各地的《Real Book》中无处不在有什么感觉，到创造出这个让一些人有很大意见或很大问题的作品是什么感觉，就它对爵士乐的影响而言。
Yeah. And he had answers to all of those questions. So was it his handwriting? It was, he says, yes, the handwriting is mine, although it looks amateurish to me now, but it's quite a hoot to see it everywhere. Someone created a real book font based on my hand. It's close, but no cigar. Wow. Throw it throwing a little bit of shade at how Leonard there. Did they have a sense of the phenomenon that it was going to become when they were making it? Definitely not. So on that note, he says, we had no idea in our wildest dreams that
是的。他对所有这些问题都有答案。那么那是他的笔迹吗？是的，他说，是的，笔迹是我的，虽然我现在看起来觉得很业余，但看到它到处都是真是太搞笑了。有人根据我的手写体创建了一种Real Book字体。很像，但还不够完美。哇。稍微吐槽了一下Leonard。他们在制作它时，是否意识到它会成为一种现象？绝对没有。关于这一点，他说，我们做梦也没想到
would become the phenomenon that it is. Countless times we've personally seen the real book used in bars, clubs, schools, and wedding receptions. It's everywhere. In 2018, I visited a friend of a cousin who had a home recording studio and there were six real books scattered around the room. And if he's keeping up this level of secrecy, you can't just point to him and say, hey, I did that. That must be a really tough temptation. If I'm like, if I see my book that the carton I did for the, for 9% visible out in the world, you bet. I'm gonna say, well, hey, I'm that guy.
它会成为现在的这种现象。无数次我们亲眼看到《Real Book》在酒吧、俱乐部、学校和婚礼招待会上被使用。它无处不在。2018年，我拜访了一位表亲的朋友，他有一个家庭录音室，房间里散落着六本《Real Book》。如果他一直保持这种保密程度，你不能直接指着他说，嘿，那是我做的。那一定是一个非常大的诱惑。如果我，如果我看到我为99% Invisible做的图表出现在世界上，你打赌。我会说，嘿，我就是那个人。
He said to do that for like 40 years and never seen anything about it. You know, I guess, you know, some of the bigger issues with the real book that we talk about, you know, the kind of, you know, the copyright and the codification of a style. Did he have any sort of insight into that kind of thing? Yeah, it's really interesting what he said about that. So, and now I'm quoting directly from what he wrote to me. The real book truly changed the world in many good ways, but also not so good.
他说做了40年却从来没见过关于它的任何东西。你知道，我想，你知道，我们谈论的关于《Real Book》的一些更大的问题，你知道，那种，你知道，版权和风格的编纂。他对此类事情有什么见解吗？是的，他说的关于这一点的内容非常有趣。所以，现在我直接引用他写给我的话。《Real Book》确实在许多方面改变了世界，但也带来了一些不太好的影响。
The intent was to create a tool for learning tunes, but not something to be used on the bandstand. Its proliferation into clubs created a negative effect, seemingly dictating what and how to play. Wow, well, that's, he's really hitting the nail on the head. And actually even more on that, he says, never was there any intent to codify anything.
其初衷是创造一种学习曲目的工具，而不是在舞台上使用的东西。它在俱乐部中的泛滥产生了一种负面影响，似乎在支配着演奏什么以及如何演奏。哇，好吧，他真的说到了点子上。事实上，关于这一点他甚至说，从来没有任何编纂任何东西的意图。
The book was meant to help people learn tunes, and beyond what is in the book, it's the responsibility of the musician to listen to as many versions as possible to form one's own sense of how to play the tune. That's why we listed some different recording sources at the bottom of tunes. Every recording has its own tempo and key, you know, melodic interpretation form and reharmonizations and therein lie many opportunities to create your own version. Wow. That is so interesting because he basically agrees with most of the
这本书旨在帮助人们学习曲目，而在书中的内容之外，音乐家有责任尽可能多地聆听各种版本，以形成自己对如何演奏这首曲目的理解。这就是为什么我们在曲目底部列出了一些不同的录音来源。每一段录音都有其自己的节奏和调性，你知道，旋律诠释形式和重新和声，其中蕴含着许多创造你自己版本的机会。哇。这太有趣了，因为他基本上同意大多数
critiques of the real book that, that people had when you talk to them. Yeah. He's essentially saying almost the exact same thing that Carolyn Wilkins said, you know, the Berkeley professor that we talked to towards the end of the piece, basically almost even word for word. It's kind of amazing. And what's also striking is that he basically says the same thing that Nicholas Payton, who's the musician that we talked to, also said about the real book. You know, if you remember, Nicholas Payton was saying that you can't really learn jazz from a book. At all, yeah. And B, in his answers, says,
人们在与你交谈时对《Real Book》的批评。是的。他本质上说的和Carolyn Wilkins说的一模一样，你知道，我们在节目快结束时采访的那位伯克利教授，基本上几乎逐字逐句。这真是太神奇了。同样令人震惊的是，他基本上说了和Nicholas Payton，也就是我们采访的那位音乐家，对《Real Book》所说的一样的话。你知道，如果你还记得，Nicholas Payton说你不能真正从书本上学习爵士乐。完全正确，是的。而B在回答中说，
I think books are fine for theory and learning tunes, but no amount of book reading will substitute for the actual act of playing music. Feel, timing, groove, and improvisation need to be learned by doing. It's kind of amazing that he is saying basically the exact same thing that we heard from Nicholas Payton here.
我认为书本对于理论和学习曲目很好，但阅读再多的书也无法替代实际演奏音乐的行为。感觉、节奏、律动和即兴创作需要通过实践来学习。他说的基本上和我们从Nicholas Payton那里听到的一模一样，这真是太神奇了。
Yeah, that's really remarkable. What about this need for anonymity? Is this something that, I mean, obviously at this point, if people knew about it, he's not going to prosecute for anything really realistically at this point. So what is that all about? Yeah, you know, it kind of seems like he likes the mystery and he likes keeping up the mystery. I'm gonna quote again from what he wrote, the internet is full of articles and YouTube videos about the real book and chat rooms all over the web are rife with discussions about its origins
是的，这真的很了不起。那么这种对匿名性的需求呢？这是某种，我的意思是，显然在这一点上，如果人们知道了，他现在实际上不会因为任何事情而被起诉。那么这到底是怎么回事？是的，你知道，他似乎喜欢这种神秘感，并且喜欢保持这种神秘感。我再次引用他写的内容，互联网上充斥着关于《Real Book》的文章和YouTube视频，网络上的聊天室里到处都是关于其起源的讨论
with zillions of different opinions. That's what's fun about it. Keep the mystery alive. Why mess with an urban legend? You know, I like this guy. I couldn't agree more. Let's not mess with it. Let him have his anonymity. I don't think we'll mess with it. Sounds good. Well, thank you, Macal. This was so much fun. Thanks Roman. Thanks so much. 99% invisible was produced this week by Macell McAvenall in April 2021. Edited by Emmett Fitzgerald Music by Swan Real. Mixed by Amida Ganatra.
有着无数种不同的观点。这就是它的乐趣所在。让神秘感保持下去。为什么要破坏一个都市传说呢？你知道，我喜欢这个人。我完全同意。让我们不要破坏它。让他保持匿名吧。我不认为我们会破坏它。听起来不错。好吧，谢谢你，Macal。这太有趣了。谢谢Roman。非常感谢。99% Invisible本周由Macell McAvenall于2021年4月制作。由Emmett Fitzgerald编辑。音乐由Swan Real创作。由Amida Ganatra混音。
Special thanks this week to author and professor Gerald Horn, who we also interviewed for this story. You can check out Nicholas Peyton's music at Nicholas Peyton.com and follow him on Instagram at Nicholas Peyton. If you want to read more history of fake books, check out Barry Kernfeld's books, pop song piracy and the story of fake books. Kathy too is our executive producer. Kurt Colestead is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Sarah Bake, Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Gabriella Gladney, Martin Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Le, Lashma Dawn, Jacob Maldonano-Madina, Nina
本周特别感谢作家兼教授Gerald Horn，我们也为这个故事采访了他。你可以在NicholasPeyton.com查看Nicholas Payton的音乐，并在Instagram上关注他@Nicholas Payton。如果你想阅读更多关于假书的历史，请查看Barry Kernfeld的书，《流行歌曲盗版》和《假书的故事》。Kathy Too是我们的执行制片人。Kurt Colestead是数字总监。Delaney Hall是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括Sarah Bake, Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Gabriella Gladney, Martin Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Le, Lashma Dawn, Jacob Maldonano-Madina, Nina
Pautak, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. Home to the Oakland Roots soccer club, of which I'm a proud community owner. Other teams may come and go, but the roots are Oakland first
Pautak, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg，还有我，Roman Mars。99% Invisible的标志是由Stefan Lawrence创作的。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的Pandora大楼。在美丽的。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。这里是奥克兰根足球俱乐部的所在地，我是该俱乐部的骄傲社区所有者。其他球队可能会来来去去，但根基永远是奥克兰
always. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our newly launched discord, which has over 2000 members at this point. We're talking about the power broker on there. We're marrying out about architecture. There's even a music channel so you can post your favorite jazz tunes and also talk about this episode, which is an all time favorite of mine. But please do not try to start an amateur internet detective hunt looking for the real book authors because that is a mystery. That should stay a mystery. There's a link to that discord as well as every past episode of 99PI on our website. It's 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
永远。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，以及我们新推出的Discord，目前已有超过2000名成员。我们在那里讨论《权力掮客》。我们在那里谈论建筑。甚至还有一个音乐频道，你可以发布你最喜欢的爵士乐曲目，也可以讨论这一集，这是我个人最喜欢的一集。但请不要试图发起业余互联网侦探搜寻来寻找《Real Book》的作者，因为那是一个谜。那应该保持为一个谜。我们的网站上有那个Discord的链接以及99PI的每一集往期节目。网址是99pi.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。